This is the brief on hate
speech, free speech, and the
latter of escalation.
OK, so the source material, it
pushes back on treating words as
violence.
The argument using private power
companies, online mobs for
instant punishment of speech,
well that just kicks off a
spiral that gets out of control.
The ladder of escalation.
Think 1914 Sarajevo.
One act sparked a global
cascade, right?
Same idea.
Now a tweet leads to pylons
getting fired, ruining
reputations.
You just end up with shouting,
not real debate.
Second, know the huge
difference.
Legal limits versus private
enforcement.
U.S. law like the Brandenburg
rule has a high bar protecting
speech unless it directly
incites immediate violence.
But platforms, employers, mobs.
They don't follow that they're
efficient enforcers, using
doxing or getting people fired
for instant punishment.
Finally, how to stop it?
It's about protecting the
square.
Basically.
Use procedure, not immediacy.
Institutions need to step back
from the quick hit of cancel
culture.
Handle disputes formally,
legally.
Let even ugly arguments happen
in public.
Choose procedure over purge.
Those quick wins often breed
much bigger conflicts down the
road.
Welcome to the debate.
Our discussion today, It centers
on a really foundational
tension.
It comes from source material
exploring the relationship
between, well, public speech
that's seen as offensive and the
immediate impulse, often through
private means, to punish it.
You know, doxing, getting fired,
social cancellation.
Right.
And the central question we're
grappling with is, is this
immediate non legal punishment
of what's often called ugly
speech?
Does it pose an inherent
systemic danger?
Does it ignite some kind of
uncontrollable ladder of
escalation threatening civil
society?
Or, alternatively, are these
consequences just, well,
unnecessary, maybe even
manageable part of modern civic
accountability?
Exactly.
And I'll be arguing that these
private punitive actions, they
dangerously substitute
established legal procedure with
raw, immediate outrage.
And in doing so, they accelerate
conflict and create structural
vulnerabilities that I think
mirror some historic patterns
of, frankly, global violence.
OK, and I'll be arguing that
while yes, the consequences of
being cancelled are severe,
often ruinous for the
individual, the analogy that
links these localized social
consequences to catastrophic
historical escalations like,
say, world wars, well, it's
rhetorically powerful, sure, but
I think it ultimately overstates
the risk.
Private consequences, however
harsh, seem functionally
distinct from the state level
mechanisms that truly Dr.
structural conflict.
So the core of my position is
this, advanced polities, they
really rely on procedural
integrity, but we seem to be
increasingly substituting that
with what I might call cathartic
efficiency.
The speed, the often anonymous
nature of private punishment
where you have platforms,
employers, activist publics
acting as these hyper efficient
enforcers is I think
fundamentally corrosive.
The source material actually
captures this perfectly when it
says words are being turned into
events, speech is being treated
as violence.
And that transition, it creates
a dangerous political economy of
outrage where the
instrumentality of screaming
replaces argument.
And this is critical because
private power just bypasses
constitutional limits.
It ignores legal doctrines like
Brandenburg, which, you know,
sets a very high bar.
Speech has to incite imminent
lawless action before the
government can step in.
Private power operates at a much
lower, much more subjective bar.
So when we empower these raw
instruments of private
annihilation, we're basically
abandoning the necessary goal to
protect the square, that public
space where even ugly arguments
need to be tolerated for
rocedural stability.
And the result?
Well, you generate martyrs and
this simmering political
resentment.
Well, I come at this really from
a need for conceptual clarity,
especially regarding scale.
My thesis is that while
professional ruin is absolutely
real and devastating, the
analogy linking these sort of
localized consequences to huge
structural global conflicts, it
feels strained when the source
material uses the assassination
of Franz Ferdinand and Sarajevo
or the Treaty of Versailles as a
blunt illustration of how small
axe cascade.
I'm sorry but I just don't quite
buy that firing someone for a,
let's say, shouty tweet
genuinely creates the material
conditions for global war.
Right.
The human impulse to punish
offensive speech?
OK, the source acknowledges.
It's an ugly human instinct.
It mentions the dueling code
logic, but modern professional
consequence like being fired.
It feels like a structural
response, maybe, but not
necessarily a violent one.
In the same vein, it's a
response to a perceived moral
breach within a specific
context, usually employment or a
platform's terms of service.
And I think to avoid unnecessary
structural panic, we should
probably focus on these as
contained consequences rather
than just assuming every single
purge generates unstoppable
revolutionary radicalism.
You know, the way true political
purges might have fueled figures
like Marx, Mao, or Che.
That comparison of scale feels
like it misrepresents the actual
power dynamic at play today.
That WIV right parallel is
powerful, I grant you, but it
does make me wonder, are we
perhaps overstating the case?
Let's maybe dig into that
analogy itself a bit more.
That's a compelling argument you
make about the danger of pure
outrage.
But have you considered whether
that historical example of World
War One, which was, you know, a
systemic conflict based on
entrenched national alliances,
complex mobilization schedules,
deep material grievances?
Is it truly analogous to, say,
an employer terminating an
employee over a viral video
clip?
Like that student suggesting we
should bring back political
assassinations?
Doesn't that analogy maybe
stretch the concept of
escalation a bit too far?
We're comparing state actions
leading to war with essentially
private employment decisions.
OK, I agree that linking a
single tweet to the outbreak of
WWI, Yeah, that sounds like
hyperbole if you focus purely on
the actors involved.
Of course, firing an HR manager
isn't the same as mobilizing the
Imperial German Army.
But let me offer a slightly
different perspective.
I think the author is focusing
more on the logic of the system
involved.
The logic.
OK, Yeah.
The observation is that small
acts of political violence map
into larger wars when the system
is brittle, or when fear and
revenge become the organizing
logics.
The latter here.
It's structural.
It's not necessarily physical.
So treating a tweet as a major
political event and then
circumventing established due
process or legal remedy to deal
with it, that's substituting
what the source calls violence
is currency over law is
currency.
When the most reliable lever for
political action becomes
immediate performative outrage,
will actors learn to weaponize
it?
Right.
And that creates exactly the
kind of cycle of repression and
new radicalism the source warns
about.
And furthermore, that Versailles
analogy, it warns that these
punitive solutions, they aren't
really solutions at all.
They might just be a long
ceasefire, allowing grievances
to fester and maybe resurge
later in a much uglier way.
But.
Who exactly is doing the
escalating here?
If an employer decides that,
say, the reputation risk of
employing someone who publicly
advocates for assassination is
just too high for their
business, isn't that a contained
economic decision based on
mitigating risks to the firm?
Why should a private entity be
morally or even structurally
obligated to withstand that kind
of self-inflicted public
pressure just to maintain some
abstract procedural purity?
The state has that obligation,
sure, under the 1st Amendment,
but does a private business
well.
I'd argue the obligation isn't
purely moral, it's strategic.
When the decision to fire
someone is driven purely by the
fear of a collective digital
punishment, a Twitter mob, we're
effectively teaching the public
that the fastest path to
justice, or maybe just
vengeance, is to bypass all
procedure entirely.
We're training actors,
individuals, and groups to
substitute established legal
mechanisms with raw outrage.
And when we do that, I think we
increase the brittleness of the
entire system.
We need institutions, both
private and public, to
demonstrate some resilience to
moral panic, strategically
choosing procedure over the,
let's face it, cheap governance
of catharsis.
OK.
And this leads right into the
core danger, which is how we
define consequence.
The source argues that the
private sector uses efficiency.
You do not persuade, you cancel.
You do not persuade, you void
livelihoods.
And it suggests this constitutes
a kind of structural violence,
or even uses the term private
lynchings.
The argument goes.
If society generally agrees to
treat words as violence, then
the inevitable response is that
others will answer with violence
too, whether literal or
structural, and that just
perpetuates the spiral.
We have to resist this modern
temptation to think that a quick
purge of the offending person
actually buys any lasting peace.
An essay just come.
At it from a different angle,
while termination is certainly
ruinous, devastating even, I
think we have to maintain a
clear, definitional barrier
between professional ruin and
literal violence.
To call job loss structural
violence, while maybe
rhetorically powerful, feels
analytically unhelpful.
It's its own kind of rhetorical
escalation, isn't it?
If an individual's public speech
represents what their community
or workplace sees as an
intolerable assault on the
project of a life, or maybe just
a core moral value, consequences
are probably going to follow,
often outside a courtroom.
The right to free speech,
fundamentally, is freedom from
stick interference, not freedom
from social or professional
consequence altogether.
If a community believes certain
speech causes real harm, maybe
economic harm to the employer or
emotional harm to colleagues,
why should the impulse to
contain that harm automatically
be considered an escalator
towards World War One?
Is the threat of losing your job
not in some cases, a legitimate
contains societal tool against,
say, profound intolerance or
recklessness.
But.
The key distinction, surely, is
due process.
When you lose your livelihood
because of a court judgment,
ideally there's procedure,
there's evidence, there's
appeal, there's transparency.
When you're fired because of a
Twitter mob, well, there's
usually none of that.
And that's precisely why the
source uses strong terms like
structural violence or private
lynchings.
It's the removal of fundamental
procedural rights outside any
established legal framework.
It's often unappealable,
sometimes anonymous vengeance.
If we allow private power to
execute these kinds of
consequences without any real
procedure, we're essentially
endorsing a system of justice
based on efficiency or maybe
popularity rather than fairness.
And that instability, that's the
true structural danger, I think.
But the.
Courts don't, and frankly
shouldn't, protect you from
every social or professional
consequence if you choose to
engage in public rhetoric that's
fundamentally hostile to your
professional environment or
community standards.
Those consequences seem almost
inherent to the social contract,
don't they?
Not necessarily proof of
systemic structural violence
about the tip over.
We're talking about the
mechanisms of social
accountability, however messy
they are.
The source itself cites the
dueling code as a historical
record of what humans do when
quote honor outranks law.
Maybe private consequence today
is simply the contemporary
predictable manifestation of
that same instinct.
It's how social boundaries and
honor are managed, perhaps
clumsily, in the 21st century.
It is an automatic proof that
society is fracturing towards
war.
OK.
Let's shift then towards the
proposed solution, because this
is where the theory has to meet
reality, right?
The source prescribes action
like protect the square and
train employers and platforms to
resist performative fury.
Now that sounds admirable,
certainly, but is it actually
realistic?
The author himself observes that
rapid, large movements like mass
migrations, for instance,
predictably provoke a defense
that will harden law and treat
whole populations as threats.
Right.
That's a key point, so.
If predictable politics leads to
this kind of hardening response,
why would predictable social
fury against genuinely ugly
speech be contained?
Just by asking institutions to
sort of passively absorb a
fence, it feels like we're
asking corporations and
universities to defy some pretty
fundamental predictable human
and political dynamics.
That's.
An interesting point, though I
might frame it a bit
differently.
We aren't arguing for pure
passivity, I don't think.
We're arguing for procedure as a
long term strategy, one that
requires, as the source says, a
horizon longer than immediate
feeling.
The goal isn't purely
sentimental, like just
tolerating everything.
It's strategic.
If we actively invest in legal
remedies for speech that does
cross the line into credible
threats or defamation, we
actually strengthen law as
currency.
The fact that it's difficult to
protect the square doesn't
negate the necessity of trying
to protect it.
That short term cathartic purge,
the quick firing to appease the
mob.
It creates resentments and
cynicism that are strategically
disastrous in the long run.
Just as the source warns, short
victories of moral cleansing can
become decades of blood.
Procedural governance, even if
imperfect, seems like the only
viable long term defense against
a perpetual cycle of outrage and
vengeance.
But.
Practically speaking, how does
an employer strategically choose
procedure over efficiency when
they're facing potentially
immediate financial ruin from a
boycott or advertisers pulling
out?
What's the actual practical
mechanism here?
Can you give us an example of
how a corporation which, let's
be honest, generally exists to
maximize profit, effectively
absorbs that level of offense
and protects the square when
faced with mass performative
fury without suffering extreme
economic damage?
Well, the.
Mechanism I think lies in
institutional resistance and
real clarity in internal policy.
Before a crisis hits,
institutions have to
strategically calculate that the
long term cost of constantly
catering to public outrage,
which let's face it, constantly
shifts its targets and
standards, is ultimately higher
than the short term cost of
standing firm on due process and
clear, predefined, ideally non
political employment standards.
This needs proactive commitment,
For example, explicitly stating
ahead of time that employees
will only face termination for
speech that violates specific,
predefined internal behavioral
codes, or perhaps speech that
rises to the legal standard of
incitement or harassment, not
merely for offending a temporary
social media consensus.
That kind of clarity actually
raises the cost and lowers the
effectiveness of external
outrage campaigns, making them
less efficient and hopefully
less weaponizable over time.
That.
Is certainly an admirable
ambition, but it does require a
level of institutional courage,
doesn't it, which feels
increasingly scarce in our
current environment when the
market seems to reward rapid
responsiveness to social
pressure.
Demanding that kind of
institutional rigidity?
Well, it sounds like demanding
that entities willingly suffer
significant financial harm for a
somewhat abstract societal good
procedural stability that might
seem very far removed from their
immediate bottom line and.
That right there is precisely
the definition of the problem
we're discussing.
When private power consistently
chooses short term efficiency or
appeasement over long term
stability and procedure, the
entire structure does become
more brittle, and that
potentially sets the stage for
the kind of dangerous escalation
the source material cautions
against.
So.
To sum up my position, it
remains rooted in the structural
risk we run when we bypass legal
procedure for that immediate,
often satisfying sense of moral
satisfaction.
The impulse to cancel might
provide cheap, emotionally
resonant governance in the
moment, but it weaponizes
outrage, it creates martyrs, and
it risks dissolving a civilized
polity into systems governed by
popularity contests and
instantaneous private lynchings.
The long term strategic focus I
maintain has to be on due
process, toleration within legal
bounds and strengthening law as
currency.
Indeed, my position in summary,
is that the argument linking
localized job loss and social
ostracism directly to
catastrophic historical
escalation like the world
shaking events starting in 1914
is fundamentally A rhetorical
overstatement, however
well-intentioned.
While we absolutely must fight
for procedural fairness within
all institutions, societal
consequences for speech that
falls outside legal protection?
Well, they're likely a natural,
perhaps unavoidable, and often
contain function of a
functioning, if admittedly
imperfect, polity.
We need to address the real
consequences of offensive speech
without necessarily falling into
a trap of structural panic about
impending societal collapse.
Indeed, the material certainly
provides essential insights into
this very complex trade off
between, on the one hand, the
immediate desire for moral
purity or accountability and, on
the other, the crucial
maintenance of procedural
stability and the.
Central tension definitely
remains trying to determine the
true magnitude of that claimed
ladder of escalation within our
contemporary civic culture, and
deciding whether we're dealing
primarily with contained social
pain and adjustment or genuinely
witnessing the early stages of
systemic collapse.
A question worth pondering.
Welcome back to the Deep Dive.
Today we're really getting into
something complex.
We're unpacking some sources
looking at this, this tension,
you know, free speech versus
this growing idea that words
themselves are violence.
Right.
And that paradox is exactly what
we're focusing on.
The main source we're diving
into uses this concept called
the ladder of escalation.
The ladder.
Of escalation, yeah.
It basically maps how these
small things maybe an online
comment a bit of conflict can
just the low.
Up.
They trigger these huge
irreversible consequences
politically, socially,
everything so like.
Small spark, big fire.
Exactly.
And the source warns that
today's heat of the moment
reaction can lock in decades of,
well, really negative outcomes.
Nobody intended and the.
Author got into this because of
something happening right now,
but then connects it way back.
Historically, philosophically,
that's what's.
Really interesting the pivot
they make, and they start by
talking about their own
background, which I found kind
of fascinating.
Oh yeah.
How so?
Well.
The author mentions not too long
ago they were deep in these
super technical, almost sterile
online debates.
Things like metric, attribution
metric.
Attribution.
OK, so like figuring out where
website clicks come from, that
kind of thing.
Exactly.
Or like anger tech strategy for
SEO.
You know, really niche technical
stuff, low stakes intellectual
sparring mostly, right?
Purely data numbers, no real
moral weight behind arguing if a
click came from source A or
source B.
Precisely contained procedural.
It affects maybe ad revenue, not
someone's life, not their
reputation.
But now, the author says they've
completely shifted.
Shifted.
How they?
Describe themselves now, maybe a
bit tongue in cheek, as someone
defending ugly speech.
And with this they're quoting
the gospels, John and Luke in
online arguments.
Wow.
OK, that's that's a huge leap
from SEO tactics to quoting
scripture to defend unpleasant
speech it.
Is it tells you they see the
current situation not just as
another argument to win, but as
something foundational breaking
down.
They feel they have to reach for
these deeper, older principles
so.
The fight isn't about data
points anymore, it's about
whether the whole structure of
public argument can even survive
this pressure cooker
environment.
Yeah.
When the ability to say
something popular, maybe even
offensive, feels like it's being
crushed not by law but by
private power, by market forces,
then the technical stuff just
falls away.
You look for bedrock legal
principles, philosophy, or like
here, even ancient wisdom.
It's about defending the
process, the procedure over just
feeling good right now.
OK, so.
That sense of crisis brings us
straight to the event that
kicked this whole reflection
off.
And it started with something
real world, right?
A tragedy?
Yes.
A very specific tragic incident.
The author talks about a high
profile killing, something that
happened publicly and their
words are stark.
It lit the feeds like an
accelerant.
Just instant ignition online.
And then then right in the
middle of all that tension, this
clip goes viral.
It's a student saying something
just incredibly inflammatory and
frankly foolish.
Like we should bring back
political assassinations.
Terrible timing, terrible
statement.
The.
Worst, It was like throwing
gasoline on the fire and the
reaction?
Instantaneous.
Overwhelming.
How?
So the Internet.
Basically mobilized.
A hunt began.
The student was doxed.
Name, location, everything out
there.
Then the institutions panicked.
Firings, forced resignations,
public denunciations pouring in
from everywhere like a.
Digital mob basically.
Yeah, and the author calls the
appetite for retribution
contagious.
It wasn't about law or due
process.
It was just this fast
destructive moral cascade people
felt they had to join in
condemning.
Almost like self preservation
and this whole.
Episode is used to illustrate
what the source calls the the
perverse moral physics of our
time.
What does that mean exactly?
It's the.
Crux of the issue, words are
being turned into events.
Speech is being treated as
violence.
Yeah, if you accept that premise
that's saying something
offensive is violence, then the
response has to be immediate,
severe, like defending against a
physical attack, so.
The reaction isn't based on
actual harm, but on the level of
offense.
Yeah, moral outrage.
Precisely.
And the danger, the source
warns, is that this kind of
escalation has no natural
ceiling.
It just keeps going up if
there's.
No ceiling.
Then every misstep, every dumb
comment, gets treated like an
existential threat requiring,
well, existential consequences.
Exactly.
And we see this playing out
constantly in the digital world.
The source calls it the civic
ladder in miniature, and it's
brutally efficient.
OK.
Breakdown the digital pathway.
How does it work it?
Starts small, often
performatively.
A tweet, right?
Maybe something edgy or poorly
thought out and that.
Tweet becomes a pile.
On massive self generating
outrage, hundreds, thousands of
people dog pilots it jumps.
Offline.
Immediately that digital
momentum turns into real world
consequences.
Suddenly it's about someones
job.
It becomes a termination or
being professionally
blacklisted.
It leads.
To.
Reputational punishment like a
digital scarlet letter, the
source implies it follows you,
makes you unlivable,
unemployable in your field, a
kind of social death and.
This whole process fuels
something the author calls the
political economy of outrage.
Can you unpack that?
It sounds important.
It's.
Critical.
It's not just about feelings.
It's instrumental.
Outrage becomes a tool, a
currency.
The structure rewards screaming
over arguing.
How does?
Outrage become currency.
How does it pay?
Well, for those leading the
charge, outrage drives clicks,
engagement, visibility, all
monetizable.
For those joining in,
participating in the purge
offers a kind of moral
validation.
It signals their purity, keeps
them safe.
So.
You don't win by being right or
persuasive, no.
You win by being the loudest,
the most effective at mobilizing
punishment.
You win by showing you can
destroy someone's livelihood
faster than the other side.
The whole incentive structure
points towards annihilation, not
discussion.
Yeah.
Why spend time crafting A
nuanced argument when you can
just mobilize outrage, get
someone fired, and score moral
points and maybe even clicks in
the process?
That makes the latter really
hard to step off of.
Right.
And to really hammer home how
dangerous the spiral is, the
author does something bold.
They yank us out of the Twitter
feeds and drop us right into
Sarajevo 1914.
Wow.
OK, that's a huge jump,
connecting a student's dumb
comment to the start of World
War One.
Why that specific historical
moment?
Because.
It illustrates the danger of
systemic brittleness perfectly.
We're talking about the
assassination of Archduke Franz
Ferdinand.
Gavrilo Princip fires a pistol.
A single.
Event A local.
Act.
Exactly.
A local act in a relatively
small city.
But because the European
political system at the time was
this tangle of alliances,
obligations and imperial pride,
that single shot triggered a
global cascade.
Mobilizations, declarations of
war, The whole House of Cards
came down.
It wasn't.
The ACT itself, but the fragile
system it hit, the context was
everything, precisely.
The assassination was the spark,
but the system was the dry
Tinder, and the parallel the
author draws is this.
Our current system, fueled by
this political economy of
outrage and the instant
enforcement power of platforms,
is also brittle.
A small digital offense can
trigger systemic consequences
just like that shot did, and
the.
Source doesn't stop at 1914.
It argues the way WWI ended
actually set up WWI.
It talks about the Treaty of
Versailles in 1919.
Yeah, the.
Pause that wasn't Versailles is
presented as this moment where
the system completely failed to
absorb the conflict in a healthy
way.
The treaty was punitive,
humiliating, basically built on
revenge, not reconciliation.
So it.
Didn't put the fire out, it just
banked the coals.
That's.
A good way to put it, it
functioned less like a real
settlement and more like a long
ceasefire.
It gave everyone time to nurse
their grievances, especially
Germany feeling humiliated and
crushed by reparations.
It created the perfect
conditions for radicalism and
eventually the monstrous
reconstitution of violence that
was WWII.
That's.
Sobering.
The lesson being, if you try to
completely annihilate your
opponent morally or financially,
whether it's a nation in 1919 or
an individual online today,
you're just.
Guaranteeing they'll be back
angrier, maybe more organized,
because you've left them with
nothing to lose and a powerful
story of victimhood.
So the.
Historical pattern is clear.
Small acts ignite big conflicts
when the system is fragile, and
especially when fear and revenge
take over as the main drivers
instead of, say, law or
negotiation.
Exactly.
And bringing it back to today,
if our public square is designed
to react to every offense with
maximum destructive force, well,
we shouldn't be surprised when
small online spats keep blowing
up into major crises, OK?
So this historical perspective
highlights a really key
distinction that seems to be
getting blurred today, the
difference between how the law
handles speech versus how, well,
how the digital mom handles it
precisely.
The US legal system,
particularly the 1st Amendment,
has these established bright
lines.
Courts have spent decades
figuring out where protected
speech ends and say incitement
begins.
The big one here is the
Brandenburg Doctrine, right?
Brandenburg, can you remind us
what that requires?
It's a high bar, isn't it?
It's a.
Very high bar.
The government can only punish
speech if it's intended to
incite imminent lawless action
and is likely to actually do so.
Both intent and immediacy are
crucial, and the.
Whole point of that high bar is
to.
Stop the government or temporary
public outrage from just
silencing unpopular views.
It's designed, as the source
puts it, to prevent majorities
from burning dissenters at the
stake.
It forces a pause, demands
evidence, prioritizes procedure
over passion.
But the.
Latter of escalation we're
seeing online the firings, the
doxing, that's not the
government doing it and.
That is the absolute key
difference.
This is private power, tech
platforms, employers, activist
groups, angry online crowds, and
the First Amendment doesn't
restrict them so they.
Become the enforcers, yes.
And they are incredibly
efficient enforcers, as the
source calls them.
Their justice is fast, cheap and
often devastating, carrying the
penalty of economic or social
ruin.
So the.
Logic is flipped.
The law is slow and careful by
design, but private punishment
is fast and procedurally empty.
Pretty.
Much the market logic or the mob
logic is if you can make someone
unemployable for saying the
wrong thing, why wouldn't you?
It signals your virtue, damages
your opponent, maybe gets you
clicks.
There's an incentive for
efficiency which bypasses all
the safeguards built into the
legal system.
That's.
Scary.
It makes your boss or the
platform you use the immediate
judge, jury and executioner for
speech which.
Brings us to the author's
defense of what they call
civilization as procedure.
The idea is that the whole point
of civilization of law is
keeping impulses from
transmogrifying into axes
keeping.
Impulses from becoming axes.
I like that it's about control,
deliberation.
Exactly.
It's the difference between a
town that argues and a town that
shoots. 1 uses law as its
currency.
The other uses violence or the
threat of professional or social
violence.
When that's the currency,
everyone's effectively armed and
ready for a purge and.
That's why the author champions
the messy, imperfect forums,
courts, newspapers, even
elections over the quick,
cathartic efficiencies of cancel
culture.
The messiness is the point.
It's a.
Feature not a bug.
These messy processes force us
to slow down, deal with
complexity, use argument, follow
rules.
They demand we defend our views,
not just destroy our opponents.
The goal isn't to love offensive
speech, but to protect the
mechanism that allows us to
argue about it.
Because if you ditch procedure,
all that's left is the axe, OK?
So defending procedure leads the
author to take a stance that,
well, it seems pretty
controversial.
They defend a specific public
conservative figure, someone
even, they admit is seen by many
as coarse, opportunistic, maybe
even a paid agitator.
Why go there?
Yeah.
It's definitely a provocative
move, but the author seems less
interested in the figure
themselves and more in what
their rhetoric did to the public
conversation.
What function did it serve and
what?
Was that function, according to
the source the.
Argument is that this figures
confrontational style.
Love it or hate it forced people
to grapple with fundamental
questions they usually avoid in
politics.
Questions about sin, personal
responsibility, public morality,
things we often keep private.
And this.
Connects back to quoting the
gospels.
Exactly.
The source highlights that when
this figure used phrases like go
and sin no more or talked about
accountability and quasi
religious terms, it landed like
a bomb.
It was anathema to the current
civic culture.
Why would quoting scripture
about morality cause such an
explosion in a political
context?
What's the Outer's take on that?
It's a.
Really insightful point.
The author argues that in our
current climate, the concept of
sin or even just moral error has
been fundamentally rebranded.
It's not seen as a universal
human failing anymore, but as an
identity taunt an.
Identity taunt, meaning if you
criticize my actions or beliefs,
you're attacking who I am
precisely.
So being told you missed the
mark, even metaphorically, isn't
her as a comment on behavior.
It's heard as an assault on your
entire being, your life's work,
your identity.
And if the attack feels
existential, the response
becomes existential.
Immediate total annihilation is
justified that.
Really captures the the
intensity of these online
conflicts.
It's not just disagreement, it
feels like Total War and the.
Source acknowledges other
complexities too, where moral
feelings clash with political
realities like the example of
migration right the.
Tension between wanting to
support migrants feeling that
human connection, but also so
recognizing that large, sudden
influxes do predictably trigger
political defensiveness.
Yeah.
The author calls that backlash
ugly and cruel, but also
predictable politics.
It's acknowledging that deep
moral feelings don't just erase
political dynamics.
A nation state or a community
will likely react defensively to
perceived rapid change,
regardless of the morality
driving the change itself.
And.
That predictable reaction often
uses outrage as its weapon,
right.
Shaming becomes a tool, a key.
Tool naming, shaming, demanding
removal.
It's presented as a cheap, fast
governance technique.
Why bother with slow persuasion
or messy legislation when you
can just cancel someone, void
their livelihood?
But the.
Author warns this backfires.
Completely.
It might feel like a win in the
moment, but all it does is
create martyrs and resentments.
You silence one voice, but you
potentially energize their
entire movement by giving them a
potent grievance narrative
which.
Leads to the critique of what
the source calls rupture logic.
What's that about rupture?
Logic is basically the
revolutionary idea.
You see it in Marx, Mao, Che,
maybe even some modern
acceleration is that the only
way to fix things is to
violently break the existing
system.
Smash it all and something
better will magically emerge
from the rubble.
And.
History suggests history.
Suggests that's not how it
works.
Usually it just sets off a
cycle.
Repression breeds resentment.
Resentment fuels new radicalism,
which leads to more repression.
You don't get a clean slate, you
get a feedback loop of
escalating conflict.
The politics of purging, whether
literal or figurative, just
guarantees the fight comes back,
probably worse than before.
So all this history, all this
analysis of the current moment,
it brings us back to this very
primal human thing, doesn't it?
Settling scores.
The author calls it the modern
dueling code.
Yeah, it's.
Like the old frontier logic,
someone insults your honor, you
challenge them to a duel.
Immediate, often lethal
response, bypassing any legal
process and the.
Argument is we're still doing
that, just for different
weapons.
Exactly.
We're not using pistols at dawn,
but we shoot with doxing, with
algorithms, with professional
ruin.
The principle is the same.
If words are treated
structurally as violence,
meaning they trigger
consequences equivalent to
physical harm, then people will
inevitably respond with
proportionate force, structural
violence, maybe even literal
violence.
Eventually, the spiral
continues, and there's.
A danger in thinking a temporary
quiet means peace, right?
Like after a successful
cancellation.
Huge.
Danger The awful points.
Back to Versailles again.
The 1920s seemed peaceful, but
it was just a pause.
It allowed the resentful and the
defeated to regroup, rearm.
Modern ceasefires and conflicts
can work the same way.
Less about peace, more about a
tactical pause to reload.
So if.
Your main strategy is just
punish and exclude your
opponents you have.
To expect the long returns of
that strategy, you're basically
ensuring the conflict smoulders
and eventually reignites because
the underlying issues and
resentments haven't been
addressed, only suppressed.
Which?
Brings us to the author's
proposed counter strategy.
It involves something they call
a paradoxically stern mercy.
What does that mean?
It sounds contradictory it.
Does it means distinguishing
strategic thinking from pure
sentimentalism?
The author specifically rejects
the immediate emotional appeal
the don't shoot I have children
kind of argument as a basis for
policy or structural decisions.
Why?
Reject that.
Isn't compassion important,
especially given the real human
cost here?
Compassion.
Is vital, but the author argues
strategy needs a horizon longer
than immediate feeling.
Emotional appeals, while
powerful, don't fix the systemic
problems driving the escalation.
We can't run society based on
who makes the most heart
wrenching plea in the moment.
We need robust structures that
can handle conflict without
resorting to immediate
destruction.
Stern mercy means preserving the
system of argument even when the
arguments within it are ugly,
because the alternative is
worse.
OK.
So if sentimentalism isn't the
answer, and escalation is the
problem with the actual
practical strategy, how do we
protect the system the.
Author offers what they call an
ugly, simple answer.
Protect the square.
It boils down to five concrete
steps aimed at institutions and
culture.
All right.
Let's walk through them #1
sounds tricky.
Let the ugly arguments happen in
public, right?
Counterintuitive, but the logic
is if you drive ugly arguments
underground, they don't
disappear, they just fester and
radicalize and echo chambers
away from any challenge or
scrutiny.
The public square, even when
it's unpleasant, acts like a
release valve and allows for
open debate, however flawed.
Trying to sanitize it completely
just empowers the extremists who
thrive in the shadows.
OK. #2 adjudicate through
procedure, not purge this.
Means reinvesting in the slow,
messy, imperfect systems we have
Courts, disciplinary committees,
arbitration instead of
defaulting to the instant
gratification of online
cancellation procedures.
Frustrating, but it's the
barrier between impulse and acts
number.
Three, use legal remedies only
for credible threats adhering to
that high Brandenburg standard.
Yeah.
Basically, save the power of the
law for genuine imminent danger.
Stop labeling every offensive
statement a threat.
By restoring that distinction,
we lower the temperature and
reserve serious consequences for
serious actions.
Number. 4 feels really crucial.
Train employers and platforms to
resist performative fury.
This.
Is huge right now, employers and
platforms act as the rapid
response enforcement arm of the
outrage machine, often because
it's easier or safer for their
brand in the short term, the
author argues they need to be
encouraged, maybe through
policy, maybe through public
pressure, maybe even market
forces to step back to resist
the mob demanding immediate
firing for every online
transgression if they start
being the executioners, the
whole economy of outrage loses a
lot of its power and the.
Last one number 5 Encourage a
civic grammar that can absorb
offense without turning it into
capital.
This.
Is the long game the cultural
shift?
It's about trying to build a
public square where we don't
immediately reward outrage,
where offense isn't instantly
monetized or weaponized.
A culture that can maybe
tolerate disagreement or even
insult without demanding
immediate institutional
retribution.
Where we can argue about the
substance, not just react to the
tone.
So.
At the end of the day, the
choice is stark.
The messy, imperfect public
square with all its arguments,
or the torches and pitchforks of
private annihilation that's.
Exactly it.
And once you like those torches,
finding your way back down that
ladder of escalation is
incredibly hard.
The choice between argument,
however flawed, and destruction
is really the core decision it.
Really forces you to think about
what's more important, that
immediate hit of moral
satisfaction from purging
someone, or the long term health
and stability of the place where
we have to argue and.
The final warning from the
source is chillingly clear.
Those short term victories,
those moments of feeling morally
pure.
By casting someone out, they can
easily pave the way for decades
of blood, figuratively or
literally.
The latter is steep.
Going down is much harder than
going up.
So the provocative thought we're
left with from this deep dive,
is this maybe the reaction, the
rush to purge fueled by this
digital ladder is actually more
dangerous in the long run than
the original offense itself?
If destruction is the main
consequence for speaking out of
line, what kind of cautious,
fearful speech will be left, and
what kind of fragile society can
actually survive under that
constant pressure?
It's something to definitely
think about next time you're
scrolling OK?
So this piece, Hate Speech, Free
Speech and the Ladder of
Escalation, looks at how outrage
escalates, you know, driven by
private power and cancel
culture, turning speech into
real institutional harm, and
argues for sticking to procedure
over moral purges.
It's a really.
Potent argument, high stakes
like you said.
Definitely.
Let's jump straight into the
first critique focusing on
structure and coherence, right?
So while the essay really
effectively details the author's
personal theological evolution
and how that influences their
political view, the structural
connection between those two
things, it could be stronger,
much more explicit I.
Completely.
Agree.
You've got these two narrative
streams running side by side,
and they're both incredibly
powerful on their own.
Exactly.
On one side, it's deeply
personal, isn't it?
Listening to gospel readings on
hollow Jeff Cavan's reflections,
Christ saying go and sin no
more.
Very internal.
Very reflective and then bam,
you pivot hard right?
Straight into massive
geopolitical stuff.
Sarajevo 1914 First Amendment
law marks Mao.
It's quite the shift and.
That's the weakness, really.
The transition between that
internal moral grammar, that
deep conviction, and the
external structural analysis
feels, well, feels implied.
Yeah, it's not really spelled
out.
And the risk there is a reader
might just think the theological
part is, you know, nice
background color, right?
Rather than the actual engine
driving the whole argument for
procedure.
Yeah, exactly.
It could seem ornamental if
we're not careful.
So the suggestion is to make
that connection really explicit.
Use that term.
The author already uses, moral
grammar and make it the bridge.
Show how the personal faith
demands this kind of political
patience and strategy.
OK.
So how does that look in
practice?
Like concrete examples.
Well, you could directly connect
the idea of leaving sin behind,
you know, from John 811 to the
political argument.
Why do we need institutions that
allow for, say, repentance or
reform, or at least legal
consequence?
I see and then contrast that
directly with canceling.
Precisely you set up the
contrast Divine Mercy allows for
change go and sin no more versus
this modern sort of irreversible
governance technique of the
online pylon, which offers 0
path back that's.
Strong.
Yeah.
And you could even frame that
whole art of keeping impulses
from turning into axes.
Feng it's.
Like a secular version of the
discipline, learn through
liturgy.
Exactly the steadying influence
of ritual and forms the
steadying influence of
procedure.
It connects the internal
discipline to the external
structure.
OK.
So when the author talks about
needing to be strategic rather
than just, you know, reacting,
you tie.
That strategy directly back to
the moral clarity that comes
from the faith so.
You might say something like,
look, this commitment to
strategy isn't about being
heartless.
It stems directly from this
rigorous moral grammar.
Understanding how hard it is to
sin no more makes me reject
systems with no room for any
kind of fix.
Right.
That grounds the political
choice and personal principle.
Makes the whole thing feel much
more integrated.
SOLID, OK.
That feels like a really
productive Ave.
So if we've tightened up the
internal logic, let's look at
how the essay engages the reader
right from the start.
The opening antidote.
Yes, the student clip so.
The essay is really powerful,
opening that feverish occasion
of a killing, the viral clip of
the student talking about
political assassinations.
It needs to be woven throughout
the argument, not just dropped
at the beginning.
It needs to ground the whole
ladder of escalation idea.
Totally agree that opening is
explosive.
It gives the reason for the
essay.
Right?
The clip sparks the Hunt boxing
institutional panic firings.
It's the modern ladder happening
right there on the screen.
But.
Then it kind of vanishes.
Yeah, the essay moves pretty
quickly to historical parallels
like Sarajevo, which are
important, obviously, but.
But you lose that immediate,
visceral connection to now the
reader knows Sarajevo was bad,
but they're living through the
kind of thing that happened to
that student.
It feels like a missed
opportunity.
Right, it lets the argument get
a bit abstract, maybe too
quickly.
So the suggestion here is
structural.
Treat that student clip like a
recurring case study, a modern
example.
Use it to map out the rungs of
the ladder as the essay
progresses.
Exactly.
Show the sequence.
The ugly speech becomes the
pylon.
The pylon leads to the firing,
the professional ruin.
Illustrate the private power
mechanism step by step using
that incident.
OK, I like that it keeps the
abstract theory grounded in
something concrete and current.
So for instance, when the essay
gets into the legal stuff, First
Amendment, the Brandenburg
Doctrine on incitement, that's.
A perfect spot to bring the
student back in, yeah.
You contrast the legal
protections for speech with what
actually happened.
Like look, the 1st Amendment
protects speech up to a point
legally, but private power isn't
bound by that in the.
Student's case, the courts
weren't involved, but platforms,
employers, angry online groups,
they acted and that's the gap,
the danger zone we need to look
at where algorithms and doxing
effectively become the
enforcers.
Something like that.
Exactly.
Like that, and maybe bring it up
again later too, when the SSA
discusses that frontier logic.
You know where law ends.
The Wild West begins.
Use.
The doxing and firing to show
the modern version of that
right?
The author says we're not beyond
that Frontier logic in 2025 make
it hit home so.
Frame it like we haven't escaped
the frontier.
The tools look different now.
It's doxing algorithms,
professional destruction instead
of, you know, actual guns.
But the principles the same.
That student faced the frontiers
justice swift and ruinous, not a
court of law.
Yeah.
Using that one modern story
consistently anchors the big
historical points.
Sarajevo, Versailles in
something undeniably real today
shows the latter in action.
Ugly speech, then the hunt, then
the cancellation makes.
The whole thing flow better and
keeps the reader really engaged.
OK, that's two big structural
points.
Let's talk tone, specifically
around mercy and sentimentalism.
This feels crucial for keeping
the reader on board.
Absolutely.
It's a tricky area, so.
The essay's dismissal of
sentimentalism its core to the
argument, yes, but the way it's
presented could risk alienating
readers before they really get
the difference between being
heartless and being strategic.
Yeah, this is that rhetorical
tightrope walk.
The author knows it.
Even amidst the conclusions
might sound monstrous, phrases
like being paradoxically stern
about mercy or observing
sentimentalism is not policy, or
dismissing the plea Don't shoot
I have children.
They're deliberately
provocative.
And that shock value, if it's
not framed carefully right away,
could make readers just tune
out.
They might just label the author
cold or callous.
And.
Completely miss the larger
strategic point about long term
stability, which is, you know,
the whole purpose of the piece.
Exactly.
We need to make sure the reader
understands the tactical reason
for the sternness before they
hit the really stark examples.
So the suggestion is really
about sequencing and framing
front load.
The explanation introduce the
idea that strategy needs a
longer view than immediate
emotion before you get to the
examples that challenge sense of
mentality.
OK.
And maybe reframe the critique
itself slightly, not as a
dismissal of the person making
the plea, but it's an
observation about the police
limits as a tool for system wide
safety, right?
It's not saying the feeling is
wrong, it's saying the feeling
alone isn't a political
structure.
So.
Practically speaking, it might
just be about moving a key
sentence.
The draft already has that
perfect clarification.
But there is a difference
between being heartless and
being strategic.
Strategy requires a horizon
longer than immediate feeling
that line.
Needs to come.
Earlier, right before the tough
examples.
Position it so it acts as the
setup, the justification for the
stern approach that follows, so
the reader gets the why first
makes.
Sense it primes the reader to
understand the author's intent.
They hear strategic firmness,
not just harshness it.
May be soften the language
around the observation itself
without losing the core point.
Of course, instead of, I
nearingly observe that
sentimentalism is not policy,
which can sound a bit dismissive
shift.
The focus to the limitation,
yeah.
Maybe something like while that
plea don't shoot, I have
children is incredibly powerful
rhetorically, it's inadequacy as
a structural defense for
everyone means we have to look
beyond it for sustainable policy
that.
Lands differently.
It's still firm on the policy
point, but it acknowledges the
human element while focusing on
the systemic need.
It feels less like a rejection
of empathy and more like a call
for broader solutions, right?
The goal is to let the author
score message drive the tone.
Strategy is needed to prevent
long term bloodshed.
Rather than letting the reader
get hung up on the potentially
harsh sounding language out of
context, keep them aligned with
the strategic purpose.
Exactly.
It's.
About ensuring the argument
lands with its full intended
force, hitting that balance
between unflinching and
analysis, and keeping the reader
engaged enough to hear it.
Excellent.
OK.
I think that covers the main
points for improvement,
coherence, engagement and tone
feels.
Comprehensive SO.
Just to quickly recap the three
main actionable suggestions for
the listener first really weave
that personal theological
journey, the moral grammar, into
the political argument.
Explicitly make it the clear
foundation for the strategic
stance.
Show don't just imply the
connection second.
Take that powerful opening
anecdote about the student and
the viral clip and use it as a
recurring case study throughout.
Map it onto the ladder of
escalation to make the abstract
concrete and keep it grounded in
the present.
Bring it back.
Yeah, don't let it just be an
opening hook and. 3rd carefully
calibrate the rhetoric around
mercy and sentimentalism.
Make sure you establish that
crucial difference between being
strategic and being heartless
early on to keep the audience
with you frame.
The sternness strategically
right from the outset.
Exactly.
This really is a strong piece of
thinking though, that central
connection, Sarajevo in
Versailles to today's online
escalation dynamics.
That's a genuinely insightful
core idea.
It identifies a really important
pattern.
Absolutely.
The historical depth is there,
so these.
Suggestions are mostly about,
you know, refining the
architecture around that core
insight, making sure the
structure is as solid and
compelling as the idea itself.
Well.
Put we.
Definitely encourage you to work
with these suggestions, it's
powerful stuff.
And please feel free to send the
revised version back for another
look when you're ready, we'd be
very interested to see it.
Welcome.
To the deep dive.
Today we're opening the source
material on, well, a really
volatile area of model life.
We're talking about that fraught
relationship between free
expression, offensive speech,
and how things seem to escalate
politically.
If you've been watching the news
or just scrolling online and
felt like every disagreement
just blows up into this
existential threat, well, we're
here to explore why that feeling
might actually be structurally
justified.
Yeah, exactly our mission today
really is to follow the argument
this essay we looked at it's
about understanding why
treating, you know, words as
violence, why turning speech
into something that demands
immediate action crease this
really dangerous feedback loop.
We need to see why history warns
US against prioritizing that
quick, satisfying moral purge
over patient may be slower
procedure and what's really.
Interesting about the writer.
Here is his own start turning
point.
It's not like a standard
political take.
He mentions this personal
paradox.
He used to be a contrarian, like
stirring the pot, you know?
And then he finds himself
arguing for structurally
defending even really ugly
speech from being shut down by
private power, right?
And what prompted that shift
wasn't politics, apparently, but
a change in his moral grammar,
deeper reflection.
He talks about being influenced
by daily liturgical readings,
the church calendars,
discipline.
It wasn't about switching
political teams.
It was structural.
It led him to see mercy not just
as a feeling, but as like a
necessary component for any
system that's meant to last.
That's.
A powerful idea.
Mercy as a structural defense,
it suggests moving away from
just reacting in the moment
towards a policy built for the
long haul.
Exactly.
That quick purge feels good
right now, but a policy of let's
call it procedural mercy plans
for how you eventually bring
dissenters or offenders back
into the fold somehow.
It's kind of the old story about
procedure, isn't it?
It offers a structural way to
handle conflict, and sheer
outrage just can't, OK.
So let's unpack the specific
thing that sparked this essay.
The trigger was small but
intense.
It happened after a high profile
killing, which obviously caused
huge waves online.
And then this clip went viral.
A student saying we should bring
back political assassinations.
Yeah.
That one moment really lit the
fuse for the kind of modern
reaction we see so often.
The response was immediate,
overwhelming the hunt online,
the doxing institutions
panicking, people getting fired,
public shaming.
And the author's key point here
is sharp words are instantly
becoming events.
Speech gets treated as a
violence demanding immediate
punishment and we.
See this pattern, this like
ladder of escalation everywhere
now it feels like it's speeding
up to starts with a tweet, maybe
an angry one.
That tweet sparks a massive pile
on the pile on leads pretty
quickly sometimes to someone
losing their job and then that
leads to reputational damage
that can make someone basically
radioactive.
That's this political economy of
outrage he talks about and.
The outrage is the capital in
that economy.
It's efficient, gets clicks,
attention, makes institutions
nervous.
I mean, why go through the hard
work of arguing, of trying to
persuade someone when you could
just scream, start a pile on and
get them fired?
The immediate payoff for being
righteously angry is just so
much bigger than the reward for,
you know, careful debate.
Which?
Brings us to a really critical
distinction in the source
material as something core to
U.S. law.
Legally, the system tries to
draw clear lines around speech.
The Brandenburg Doctrine, right?
Part of the 1st Amendment
framework.
It separates protected speech
from actual incitement, correct.
The government constitutionally
can't punish you just for having
a terrible idea or saying
something offensive.
The standard for unpredicted
speech, that Brandenburg test,
it's incredibly high.
The speech has to be aimed at
causing imminent lawless action
and it has to be likely to
actually 'cause it so a real
immediate call to illegal
action, not just, you know,
general angry talk.
OK.
But let me push back a bit here.
If you're running a university,
say, and a student calls for
political assassinations, isn't
getting rid of them quickly just
basic institutional self
preservation?
Why should the university have
to tolerate that, even if the
government can't prosecute
that's.
A fair question.
And it's right to the heart of
the power difference.
The 1st Amendment restricts the
government.
It forces slow, sometimes
painful procedure, due process,
a really high bar for stepping
in.
And that slowness?
It's actually a feature, not a
bug.
It's designed to protect
dissent.
But.
Private power?
You mean platforms, employers,
the angry public?
They don't have those same
constraints.
Exactly.
Private power could be an
efficient enforcer.
If I'm a Latform or an employer,
I don't need to meet the
Brandenburg standard or offer
full due process.
I can shut down speech just
because it's offensive or
embarrassing or bad for the
brand image.
That lack of a procedural
barrier is what allows modern
cancellations to happen so fast
and be so severe.
The government's hands are tied.
The mob working through private
institutions isn't.
And when?
You take away those procedural
guardrails when the system gets
brittle and runs on immediate
emotional reaction, that's when
things can really spiral.
Which leads us to history for a
pretty stark illustration of how
that quick emotional response
can cascade into catastrophe.
Yeah, we're.
Talking about that classic
historical Hinge point.
Sarajevo, June 28th, 1914.
Guerrillo Princip assassinates
Archduke Franz Ferdinand A local
radical act of violence seems
containable, right?
But the wider system was
fragile, riddled with fear,
complex alliances and demands
for immediate punishment.
That one shot triggered a chain
reaction, mobilizations, and
ultimately a World War that
killed millions.
It's the.
Ultimate cascade failure.
But the source material argues
the lesson isn't just the
assassination itself.
It's what came after the Treaty
of Versailles in 1919.
It was punitive, brittle,
humiliating, designed for
revenge, not really for
reconciliation or stability.
And the.
Psychological parallel is
fascinating.
Just like today's online mob
might seek a quick moral
cleansing by destroying
someone's reputation, the
victorious powers in 1919 wanted
a kind of total moral purge of
the losers.
And that desire for immediate
punitive justice meant
Versailles wasn't really a
settlement.
The author calls it more like a
long ceasefire, one that
allowed, in his words, a
monstrous reconstitution of
violence.
Is that basically set the stage
for World War 2?
Wow.
The pattern is terrifyingly
clear then, both internationally
and, you know, civically.
Small acts of political
violence, or maybe today's
extreme verbal provocations,
they can lead to huge breakdowns
if the system is fragile, or if
fear and revenge become the main
driving forces, which is.
Exactly why the author makes
this strong moral case for
defending what he calls the ugly
square.
His argument for tolerating even
really Uggle speech isn't about
liking the speech itself, it's
about recognizing that
civilization is procedure.
Civilization as the art of
keeping impulses from
transmogrifying into axes.
I like that phrase.
That's a good.
One, Yeah, Yeah.
The difference between a town
that functions and say, the Wild
West is simple.
Do you shoot or do you argue the
argument?
Messy, imperfect, often
defensive.
That's the currency of law and
procedure, the quick, satisfying
purge.
That's the currency of violence.
We choose courts and ballots
precisely because they slow down
that impulse for immediate
revenge.
But.
OK, doesn't that let genuinely
toxic people, people spreading
hate kind of off the hook?
If someone is constantly pushing
bigotry, isn't naming shaming
and removing them just necessary
public hygiene it?
Feels necessary?
Absolutely.
But the source argues that this
immediate purge is ultimately A
flawed strategy.
Outrage gets weaponized.
It becomes a cheap way to govern
or seem like you're governing.
It doesn't persuade anyone on
the other side.
It doesn't resolve the
underlying issues.
It just cancels jobs, ruins
reputations, and, maybe most
dangerously, it creates martyrs
and deep resentment among those
who feel silenced, not actually
argued against and.
History has shown us how this
kind of forced purification
often plays out, right?
Revolutionary rhetoric marks Mao
Che promised transformation
through radical breaks,
purifying violence.
Get rid of the bad elements.
Utopia arrives.
But what?
History actually shows is that
repression breathes resentment,
and that resentment inevitably
fuels new, sometimes even worse,
radicalism.
That feedback loop seems
unavoidable.
This desire for immediate moral
payback taps into something
really primal, like the old
dueling code.
That frontier logic talks smack.
It shot.
It's universal, the source
notes.
We haven't really moved past it.
We just have different weapons
down.
No more pistols at dawn, no.
Now we shoot with doxing, with
algorithms, with professional
ruin.
But the principle is the same.
If you treat words as violence,
you normalize using structural
violence as a response, and once
that becomes the main tool, the
escalation spiral is incredibly
hard to stop.
Which?
Brings us towards strategy.
If the real goal is long term
civic health, we need a strategy
that looks beyond just how we
feel right now.
The author points out that a
pause, like a ceasefire or the
quiet after someone's been
cancelled isn't necessarily
peace.
Exactly.
If that pause comes from
humiliation and punishment, like
your side did, it's just an
opportunity.
An opportunity for the defeated
or the ostracized group to
rearm, regroup, plan their back,
maybe with even more resentment.
If your strategy is total
annihilation, you better be
prepared for the long, often
bloody consequences.
And.
This connects back to the
author's reflections on mercy,
that structural idea.
He contrasts those immediate,
emotional please don't shoot I
have children with actual
structural policy.
Sentiment isn't strategy, right?
Strategy needs that longer
horizon beyond the immediate
catharsis.
The author mentions thinking
about Christ, saying go and sin
no more.
That shaped his view.
It argues for a structure that
sees the wrong, judges it, but
gives the person procedural
space to stop, maybe return.
That's mercy as structure,
prioritizing future stability
over that immediate satisfaction
of punishment.
So.
Boiling it down, what's the
simple answer?
What's the call to action here?
It's.
Pretty blunt.
Protect the square, tolerate the
ugly arguments in public.
Use established procedural legal
means for genuine credible
threats.
Don't rely on the mobs quick
purge just for offensive words.
Practically speaking, that means
platforms, institutions,
employers.
They need to foster a kind of
civic grammar that can handle
offense without immediately
turning it into outrage capital.
They need to resist that urge,
often profit driven towards
performative anger.
So.
Here's the final thought.
We want to leave you, the
listener, with the big lesson
from Sarajevo and from that
punitive piece of Versailles.
Is this those short term wins
you get from moral cleansing,
from crushing and humiliating
your opponents?
They often plant the seeds for
decades of conflict later.
So if we really care about
preventing the next catastrophe,
whether it's another global war
or just our society dissolving
into private vendettas and
reputational ruin, we have to
structurally choose the public
square, Ugly speech and all.
Choose that over lighting the
torches of outrage.
Because once those torches are
lit, once the purge starts,
finding the stairs back down to
procedure and de escalation
becomes almost impossible.
Think about that next time you
see one of those righteous
online pylons.
Are you contributing to a stable
settlement or just reinforcing a
very long, very brittle
ceasefire?